Lindsay:
I am Jeff Lindsay.
I was going
to introduce myself
'cause I wasn't sure
what to tell her to--
how to introduce me
as but,
I've--basically, I--
strange generalist
and entrepreneur
and web developer,
and I currently work
at NASA Ames
on some cool web stuff.
I also started
SuperHappyDevHouse,
which is a cool party
for hackers and thinkers.
And I've done
some other stuff
but you've probably
never heard of it,
although you might
have heard of Web Hooks.
I don't know,
has--is--
is this a familiar concept
with anybody here?
Okay.
A couple of you.
And the rest of you
are just, like, curious
what this thing is?
Okay. Well, you'll find out.
So I've--I've--
I guess I'm the--
at least right now,
the main evangelist
behind this concept.
Three years ago,
I kind of like was
just thinking about
HTTP callbacks,
and I kind of just gave it
this name of "web hooks"
and I guess fairly recently
people have started
to get excited about
them for some reason.
So the point of this
is to kind of share
what they are
and why they're significant,
and what's going on
in this sort of, like,
growing ecosystem
of web hooks.
So I've given a version
of this talk before,
and this time I--
I kind of want to emphasize
the programmable part
because that's kind of a--
a major influence
for why this was
significant to me
in the first place.
Because a lot of people
are associating this
with--with other things
that aren't exactly
what it's about.
So...
I--I was told
by a friend of mine
that--he was reading
about web hooks,
and he got really
excited about them,
and then he went to find out
what exactly they are
and he got
really disappointed.
And--the--what I'm--
what I think
I'm describing is--
is a, you know,
a game-changer,
but it's based on,
you know, a mechanism
that really takes one
line of code to describe.
So it seems really simple,
and so people think
it can only do simple things
when it's
quite the contrary,
as Go would be
an example of--
simple mechanics
creating rich dynamics.
So the point of this talk
is to show the implications
of this as well as,
like, what it is.
So notice
I'm dancing around it
because that's how I roll.
So at the high level,
you know,
I was kind of inspired by,
1997, Jon Udell,
who was talking about
websites as data sources
that can be reused and remixed.
And today that idea
isn't very novel.
But he kind of talked about,
you know,
"a new programming paradigm
that takes the whole Internet
as its platform."
And this was
very interesting to me,
and it kind of
manifested recently
or at, you know,
2005-ish area--era
as "The Programmable Web"
or "The Web as the Platform."
And, uh, in 2005,
John Musser
started tracking
APIs and mashups
that were on the web,
and now there's
over 1,000 APIs
and they're--it's growing
at a pretty nice rate.
So APIs and mashups,
I guess,
have become the foundation
of the programmable web--
or are they?
After thinking
about web hooks,
and fairly recently, thinking
about the programmable web,
I realized
that APIs and mashups
don't really make
a programmable web.
They make a program--
a programmatic web.
And so, for example,
Twitter--the Twitter API
lets us use Twitter
programmatically,
but it doesn't let you
program Twitter to do more.
So I--my argument
is kind of like
web hooks will bring about
the real programmable web.
So--okay,
so what are they?
I said--
I mentioned HTTP callbacks,
but here's
a little scenario.
So we have
a web service here
and his name
is Twickr.
And the user's like,
"Cool. Sign me up."
"All right.
You're all set. Now listen.
"I might find myself
with some data
"that you might be
interested in,
"that's relevant to you.
You know, "What--what do
you want me to do with it?"
And so the user says,
"All right. Hold on a sec."
And he goes off
and he hacks up some script,
and he comes back and says,
"Could you just post it here
whenever you have any?"
And the web service is like,
"Sure, why not?
But what's at that URL?"
And the user says,
"Well, it's a tiny handler
I put up on App Engine."
And the web service says,
"Well, what does it do?"
And the user says,
"It doesn't matter to you.
It does whatever I want."
That's kind of the point.
Web hooks are just simple
user-defined HTTP callbacks.
But you see what this--
what this does
is it makes the web service
become extensible
and it makes the user
become empowered.
I was--a friend of mine
was trying
to get me to explain
web hooks to her.
And she's not a programmer
but she has an iPhone,
so after
explaining this to her
she compared it
to jailbreaking the iPhone.
And I thought
about it for a minute
and I thought, "Yeah,
I guess that kind of works."
You know, it's--
it's letting users do
what they want with it.
You know, customize it,
add applications, etc.
So having web hooks
in your web service
is like jailbreaking
your web app.
It's opening
functional extensibility.
So to describe
the core mechanic
of web hooks
is very simple.
So this is a pseudo-code
example of what
the heart of implementing
web hooks looks like.
And you can dress this up
in lots of ways
and there's reasons why you
would want to dress this up.
But it's very simple.
You're making
an HTTP request
to a user-specified URL
on major events.
PayPal is probably
one of the oldest
web hook implementers.
Their Instant
Payment Notification
is a web hook.
They describe it--
"When a customer pays you,
"PayPal posts a notification
to your server
at a URL you specify."
And it's framed
as a notification
just kind of--kind of like
how I described web hooks
when I
started writing about it.
But it doesn't properly
imply the usage
it's intended for,
which is integration.
So I'll come back to that.
So I started thinking
about this in 2006,
kind of inspired by PayPal
and some projects
that I was working on,
and it was kind of like I
saw a lot of what it could do
and I was like, "Well, that's--
this is really awesome.
Why isn't this," you know,
"all over the place?
Why aren't there
web hooks everywhere?"
And I felt like
I was taking crazy pills
and I would--
I would tell people about it
and they'd be like,
"Yeah, that---that's a--"
you know, "Why not?"
And I guess today
I know why
it wasn't recognized--
is it's just--
it's just so--
you know, it's such
an abstract idea, you know.
And it's--it's like,
"It can be used for anything!"
Right?
And people don't get that.
You know, they--
they need concrete examples,
and so over
the past three years,
there's--more
and more people
have been implementing
web hooks,
and I can basically
point those examples out.
So comparing it to REST,
you know,
SOAP versus REST--
they've been around a lot longer
than the graph shows,
but, you know,
REST is much simpler.
In fact,
you could describe it
as using HTTP properly,
but it wasn't
until it got a name
that it could really
be used in discourse
to make it popular.
And so that's kind of what
I was doing
by giving web hooks a name.
And so now
we're talking about it,
and there's now a--starting
to be a discussion about it.
And actually REST and--
REST APIs and web hooks
are kind of two sides
of the same coin,
and they--
they complement each other
in--in ways that
I'll get to later,
but that's--so I just want
to give it this name
and start associating
some ideas with it.
And so now the--the--
that was all just introduction.
I've split this talk
into three sections.
And these are basically
different general ways
you can use web hooks.
So the first one is--
is Push.
'Cause this is kind of
what a lot of people
are talking about
right now.
They're talking about Push
and PubSub on the web.
And although it's not
the first time--right?
And actually,
I found this recently.
In 1998, predating RSS,
or RSS 0.92,
Microsoft submitted
an Internet draft
to extend HTTP to provide
a basic PubSub framework
called "Gina" or "Jenna"--
I don't know how
it would be pronounced--
but GENA,
General Event
Notification Architecture.
And it had
standard PubSub terms
and it added
four new methods to HTTP.
And it--
it expired eventually.
Nothing ever happened,
so in 1999, it expired.
But--and the group behind it
kind of seemed to disappear.
However, the methods
and protocol
ended up in the WebDAV
implementation for exchange,
which is interesting.
Anyway, but then in 2000,
RSS 0.92 is released.
And five years later,
it got a nice icon
and had, you know,
widespread adoption.
And it started with blog feeds
and then comment feeds,
but then it exploded
into Twitter feeds
and photo feeds
and activity feeds
and event feeds
and bookmark feeds,
and then,
even feeds of feeds.
So the name "feeds"
is kind of nice.
It kind of makes you think
of the telecom world
of data coming
directly to you.
But we know that's
not how it works, right?
Instead, we have
to go request the data
and then it gives it to us,
and we do this over and over--
Are we there yet?
You've heard this before.
This is polling.
And feeds
made sense in a world
where the feed reader
ran on the desktop
and can be pushed to--
over HTTP.
But, of course,
now we have, you know,
the--it seems like
the majority of--
of feed consumption happens
from other web applications
on servers.
And it doesn't
necessarily make sense.
And even most of
our feed readers today--
you know, Google Reader--
are web-based applications.
So we've had some,
you know,
incremental solutions
proposed.
SUP, which is the
Simple Update Protocol,
it, you know,
increases the efficiency
of consuming
large amounts of feeds.
However, it's
based on polling still
and is essentially
yet another feed.
So I couldn't help
but to think of this.
So Evan and Kellan
gave a great talk
a while back
about this Push issue,
and their proposed solution
was XMPP.
Of course.
Right?
How many of you
support XMPP?
Nobody.
Okay, that's cool.
So I have a condensed
version of their talk,
in case you missed it.
The slides kind of
speak for themselves.
Polling sucks.
Are we there yet?
Let me know
when something changes.
'Kay, thanks, bye.
XMPP PubSub.
Thank you.
Questions?
Yeah.
So that was their talk.
Pretty great point.
Polling sucks, and XMPP
is a pretty good solution
for data streams,
right?
But it's kind of heavyweight
and it does a lot
and makes for a decently
complex little system.
Luckily it's not
that hard to use anymore
with today's libraries,
but I mean,
if you look at it,
it's complicated.
And you have to,
you know--
well, I don't really want
to get into the whole XMPP thing
'cause the point is
is that it's not really
XMPP versus web hooks.
Not really.
But so Evan and Kellan
did point out that there are,
you know, extremes
when it comes to data streams.
Most data streams
will probably fall
somewhere in-between
fast and furious
and small and infrequent.
And, I guess, you know,
XMPP is pretty well-suited
for the fast
and furious feeds.
So Joshua Schachter,
who's not here, I guess?
No?
He responded to that talk
in a blog post.
He said--
he basically suggested
web hooks
as an alternative--
saying HTTP callbacks,
right?
So you know, he says,
falls comfortably between
polling and XMPP.
And I agree,
and I think that they
can cover most use cases
pretty well.
I guess, though,
the interesting thing
is a lot of people
are saying, you know,
"Web hooks--it's the new
posh way to say 'callback.'"
You know?
I think what--what
differentiates web hooks
from just saying
it's an HTTP callback
is, uh,
that it's user-defined.
And so we'll get
into that in a bit.
But go--moving on
with this Push stuff,
we've got GetPingd,
which is the standard
for discovering and subscribing
to content changes.
And they let you have--
use web hooks or XMPP,
which is nice.
And it's a good idea,
but like GENA,
you know, a speck alone
doesn't really change the world.
So yeah, although
implementation on--
so on the other hand,
you have pure implementation.
We have a service
like Gnip which is...
their main goal is to
stop polling as a service.
And so they--
they also kind of transform
protocol mechanisms, so.
You can pick your own
protocol and mechanism
for getting data streams
no matter what the feed
publisher is publishing.
So although they recently
dropped support for--
to consume XMPP
for interesting reasons,
making web hooks
their primary Push mechanism
for consuming data.
So as--in case
you're not familiar,
a quick example--
if I wanted to get
Digg updates via web hooks,
Gnip will poll Digg for me
and invoke my callback
with the content
as the new updates come in.
I could even poll
Gnip for Digg updates,
and although
that seems redundant,
it helps, you know,
ease the load on Digg
because Gnip can cache,
and it allows Gnip to provide
filtering functionality
and whatever else they want
to do to add value to this.
And yet another example
might be of Twitter,
who provides
an XMPP stream,
but I already have
polling set up
so Gnip would help--
would let me poll
instead of integrate XMPP.
So that's Gnip.
In promoting web hooks,
I sort of look up
to the way microformats work
in values and process.
It's a very sort of
ground-up, grassroots effort,
and it's, you know,
taking existing popular use--
use patterns
and then making that
a convention.
So it's sort of a--
letting...
that's why there--
there isn't, you know,
like a spec
around web hooks.
Because, first of all,
I think
it's too general of a thing
to--to write a spec for.
You can write specs
for more specific things
on top of it,
but I would rather
let interesting
implementations come up
and then we
can develop as--
as we explore
the possibilities,
then we can take
the best practices from there.
Instead of trying to,
you know--
try and think of
every possible use case
beforehand and
encode it in a document.
So but also microformats
can be viewed
as an alternative
to XML and RDF.
And Tantek is a big
microformats evangelist.
In comparing microformats
and XML/RDF
he says, well,
"Here's a new language
"we want you to learn,
and now you need to output
"these additional
files on your server.
"And it's a hassle.
Microformats lowers
the barrier to entry."
So I thought that
was kind of similar
to web hooks versus XMPP.
So I told him
about web hooks,
and he's like,
"What are they?"
And I said,
"Push over HTTP,"
because it's--
the sim--
I was trying out,
you know,
simple ways
to explain web hooks,
and he says, "How are they
different than XMPP?"
And I said, "Well, they're
just a lightweight alternative."
You know, they lower
the barrier to entry.
And he said, "Good.
XMPP needs a competitor."
And this was encouraging
coming from Tantek,
because when he talks,
you listen--
if for no other reason
than he gets the chicks.
Unfortunately, XMPP--
well, at least
in web hooks' case--
XMPP has many features
and proposals to do
PubSub and stuff that--
things that web hook doesn't do
out of the box because
it's just, you know,
making an HTTP request.
I mean--so it's--
it's not
a messaging protocol.
So in order to do PubSub
with web hooks,
you need
to have more implemented.
And that's something
that Brad Fitzpatrick
and Brett Slatkin
are--are doing
with PubSubHubHub
which they re--
HubBub--which they
recently shared at the--
at an XMPP--
XMPP meet-up
and--which was recorded,
and there was
some weird drama
about, like, web hooks
versus XMPP.
But anyway,
the point is that
Push is good.
And now there's finally
some demand for it.
For example, I--
I don't know
what would happen if GENA
was proposed again now.
But we have
some good solutions.
And XMPP seems to be
ideal when you need it,
but web hooks
generally do the job.
And they're easier
to implement.
So you might as well
default to web hooks
unless you
really need XMPP.
But I wanted
to frame this talk
as not about Push, because
that's not what it's about.
It's just a nice way
to get the social media kids
into bed with web hooks.
But hooks are really about
more than PubSub
and notifications.
And that's why
they're called "web hooks"
not "web notifications"
or something.
So instead of Push,
I was more drawn to
the "Pipes" metaphor, which
I'm sure we've all heard of
for the web.
You know, I wanted
to integrate and orchestrate
my web app--the web
applications I use--
you know, conceptually
similar to Unix pipelining.
So I thought about it,
and I know
there's not actually pipes
in this screenshot,
but, you know, pipes
are a pretty amazing feature
that let you get more
out of the commands
that you're using by letting
you chain them together.
And it sort of lets you
program without programming--
combining commands
in a way that--
that wasn't necessarily
intended by the author.
So you get some neat,
you know, emergents, right?
And it was all
from really simple--
simple infrastructure,
right?
It was--programs
have input and output.
You know, and this was
made available to the user
to reroute
however they wanted,
and that's piping,
and that's the model
that I used--
well, so it's
kind of interesting
'cause you have all
these simple little programs
that--and a lot of them,
you know, aren't very useful
by--alone, but, you know,
when you start
chaining them together,
you have something that,
you know,
might be more useful
than some of the parts.
And that kind of helped
put forth the Unix philosophy
or they were made
because of the Unix philosophy
to encourage building
these kinds of small,
composable commands.
But it doesn't work without
the output, right?
It just breaks.
Like, what's the point?
And that's kind--
conceptually,
how I'm viewing the web
and web applications,
because you can talk
to web app--
you can talk
to web applications.
You can make
requests to them.
And they can give you stuff
back when you request it,
but otherwise, they
can't really talk to us
or anything else, really.
So it's not
that they can't,
it's just that they don't
because we need to start
putting something like hooks
in so that they can.
And so these roles are--
seem to be best played
by mechanisms
that use the protocol
that the web is built on--
HTTP.
So REST and web hooks
make sense, right?
This is a backhoe,
and it's a front-loader
plus an excavator.
So we want to combine
web applications
like we can
on the command line
to get more than
the sum of the parts.
And web hooks open up
this possibility,
but like--like web APIs,
they need
to be implemented.
I don't know.
I hit a button.
So for example,
imagine Basecamp
with a bunch of hooks
for events, right?
Like a project is finished,
a to-do is completed,
a milestone is created.
These are kind of significant
events in the system.
The idea is that if you
let users write handlers
that are just web scripts
they just--
all they are is a URL--
then you can give that
to Basecamp.
And then Basecamp
can call it,
and because it's code
on the other side,
it can basically do
anything from there.
So imagine this is a URL
that points to
a Google App Engine handler
or AppJet or just
a PHP script on--on hosting.
Like hosting--
CGI-powered hosting
is completely commodotized.
You can just, like,
get it for free practically.
From there you can integrate
it with other services
or make a phone call
or order pizza
or whatever because it's code
and code can do anything.
Right?
So--so for example,
all of these applications--
SlimTimer, Remember The Milk
and Basecamp--
they all--so this
is a one-use case--
they all have their respective
specialized talents,
but they all work
around to-dos.
And so there's, like,
a duplication
of data there, right?
So if you put hooks
on all their CRUD events
then you can use their,
you know, existing APIs
to create and delete stuff
combined with hooks
to basically,
you know, kind of dumbly
create and delete this,
you know, that representation
of that to-do
on these other systems.
It kind of works pretty well,
and it's kind of dumb,
but it's--magically works
in real time.
So you're not, you know,
having to recreate stuff,
and it's kind of nice.
So web hooks enable
service integration,
which is
an interesting idea.
You know, it's--
or I should say ad hoc
because it's sort of like
letting the user
integrate your services
with each other.
'Cause usually you
would have to hard code
these things.
And so this brings,
you know,
new composability
to web applications.
And it's based on the idea
that web user--
web URLs can run code.
And code can do anything.
So when I first
thought about this,
it was the cheap
PHP hosting that--
you know,
that was all over,
and I--I thought,
"Well, that's great.
That's simple, but it
could be even simpler."
So you have
paste bins like these
and they're made to share,
you know,
formatted code or whatever.
So you can put in some code
and ask a question
and you get a URL
and you can say, like,
"Where's the data you stored?
I don't get it."
And so I was thinking
about the same thing,
but instead you
write code, right?
And this was before
App Engine and AppJet
and all the stuff.
This was just
my model for how this--
something
like this would work.
And then--so instead of just
giving you a URL to view it,
you'd get a URL to run it.
And in this case,
you know, it's--
it's--if you
can see the code,
it's checking
what operation it is.
If a project is completed
then it sets up some variables
and then sends a mail--
a message to the mailing list
saying, "Let's get drunk.
Meet in the break room."
So, you know,
you would take that URL
and just give it
to Basecamp.
And so then now,
all of a sudden,
when you finish a project,
everybody meets
for shots in the break room.
And like I said, we
have this now with AppJet,
which is, you know,
made by ex-Googlers.
But it's kind of nice.
You just hit a button,
write code,
hit save, show the URL,
and it's JavaScript,
which is not bad.
Obviously there's App Engine.
And although it's a little bit
more involved than AppJet,
for quick handlers--
although this could
very easily be fixed
by making an--you know,
something like AppJet
on top of App Engine that
makes it easier to just, like,
write code and get a URL.
And then there's other stuff
like Ruby on Rails,
hosts like Shirokuma
and all this.
So another thing that I was--
I've been working on,
playing around
with this idea--
is an extension
that's playing with
how end-users might interact
with web hooks.
'Cause I'm not being very
specific about this, right?
Because it's
sort of like up to
how people implement it.
A lot of people
have a text field
in their settings that say,
"What is the URL
for this event?"
So this extension
was kind of built on
the assumption that, you know,
it detects
some markup on the page
to discover web hooks--
you know,
assuming that
there is such a thing.
And then, you know,
like for example,
saying that
there's new photos
from your contacts
on Flickr.
And if you want to do
something when it happens,
then you just
click that event.
And what it
could do is then
pop up a little window
with a little box,
so you could just write code
and hit "Save"
and it will automatically
post that to AppJet,
register the handler with the--
with that web service,
assuming that there's
a standard protocol,
and it's--
and it's done.
Like you've just,
you know, extended Flickr
in--in line
with using it.
And that's really neat.
So of course it
requires, again,
like a standard protocol
for registering handlers
and all this.
But that's something
we can figure out, right?
It's not that hard.
And of course,
you can go back
and go to that event again,
and you can see your code
and you can change the code
and it--
that's kind of cool.
So real world examples.
I first exposed SVN-Hooks
through DevjaVu
using web hooks.
It's just Post-Commit,
Pre-Commit,
text box,
you put in the URL.
Pre-commit was neat.
If--if the URL returned,
I think, 400,
then it would not allow
the commit to continue.
A friend of mine,
CTO at PBwiki--
I talked about him so much
and I kind of used PBwiki
as a hypothetical example
that he decided
to implement them,
and so he
gave a little talk
and he really liked
what he found.
He put hooks for everything.
Like when you log in
and when you log out,
when you edit a page,
revert a page,
delete a page,
comment on a page,
and he thought
it was really fun.
I'm not sure if
it's made it to production,
but again, he said,
"It's really cool,"
and he was one of the people
that were like,
"I don't know about this."
Like a lot of things.
The idea silently spread
to the Rails guys.
If you've seen Lighthouse,
it's an issue-tracking system,
and they use them.
Tobias used them
in Shopify,
which is, you know, a hosted
shopping cart application,
and he's revamping their API
to have more web hooks
because they're very cool.
And they were one of
the earliest adopters.
And very recently they had
their one-year anniversary
using web hooks.
They're very happy with them.
Google Code
recently caught up
with the other code hosts
by providing
Post-Commit Hook.
And it was very well done.
Good job.
And so you also seem to solve
some interesting problems
like authentication.
You know, HMAC signatures
seem to be a good way to do it.
Github,
another popular one,
they were another
early adopter
and people really like them
on Github.
They have their
Post-Receive Hook
which is basically
Post-Commit.
And users have
used it to integrate,
you know, notifying
mailing lists or chat,
or working with other
project management tools,
or triggering
continuous integration--
you know, running tests,
whatever, builds.
And that's all very cool,
and they were so successful
for ad hoc integration
with whatever
the users wanted
that they decided to
formalize it into something,
you know, because everybody's
having to repeat the code
or, you know,
copy the script
and share it
with someone else.
So they made it very easy.
They basically
polled in the stuff
that was being
integrated the most
and, you know, built it
into their--their service.
So they have Service Hooks.
Built-in
service integration.
But the cool thing is
is the way they did it.
Because they had this existing
web hook infrastructure,
they just--their--these--
these--they way they integrate
these external services
like Lighthouse
and Campfire--
they're just little applets
or, you know, web scripts
running in a separate
web server locally.
So they can manage it.
And it's using their
existing web hook stuff.
So it doesn't actually go out
to, you know, the Internet.
It goes locally and then they
can manage the--the source
and support it.
And it's really neat because
they made that open-source.
So if you want to write
your own handler
for integrating Github
with, you know,
a completely new web service,
then you can fork
their--their project,
write a new handler,
push it back to them,
and they can,
you know, look it over.
They're
really simple scripts.
And then they can deploy it
and support it.
It's really cool.
And this is--I mean,
I don't see why
this can't be the standard
model for service integration.
It's just
so great and nice.
So another example of--
so now that they're
getting more popular,
there's now
web hook consumers,
so the--
on the other end, like,
I figured, well, eventually
there will be services,
you know, once we figure out
some standardization
and stuff,
there will be services
on the other end
to consume hooks.
So you can just,
you know,
take some service URL
and put it in a--
in a services web hook
and it will work directly.
But I figured
that'll be a while,
and for now people--
you know, the advanced users
that are using this--they can
write their own scripts.
Right?
But so this happened
to come about.
Run Code Run--it's a continuous
integration service.
It just works with Github.
It's--they just--
that's how they work.
You put in their URL,
into their Post-Receive Hook,
and it'll run
your continuous integration
on their service,
which is really neat.
In fact, you can--
you bas--
you can sign up
with Run Code Run
by just taking their URL
and putting it into the--
into your Github project.
So--and of course,
I mentioned PayPal.
And web hooks
make so much sense
because it's not really
about notification.
They say it's "instant
payment notification,"
but the point is is that
it's about integrating, right?
It's integrating it
with the rest
of your
shipping infrastructure
or, you know, label printing
or whatever.
In fact, there's--I--
I don't have a slide here
but there's
a whole other service
that lets you manage
post-payment operations.
And the way it works is
you just--
they give you a URL
to put in the IPN for PayPal
and then
that's how they get
all the data on
all your transactions,
and then they--you can manage
them in a nice interface
since PayPal
is kind of a pain,
and do all
this extra cool stuff.
And it's like
there wasn't even an API.
It's, like, all based
on web hooks.
One web hook, too.
So that's what
they're really great for,
even though they can be used
for, like, pushing
content updates,
which--whatever.
Jott is another example
of a web hook implementer
that doesn't know it yet.
They parse
voice over the phone
so you can do stuff with it,
like post to Twitter,
post to your blog, whatever.
They do it with--
they call them "links,"
which are just hooks.
You basically--if you
want to create a new link
for Jott, you just
give them a URL
and they post
the parsed text to it,
and then you can
do whatever you want.
So the Twitter one,
Remember The Milk--
all these things--
all they do is
it's a script
that takes the data
and then uses the API
and posts it.
So that's neat.
So it became obvious that
making adapter services
so that you can--
adapter services
that are useful
in specific cases,
for example, mail,
if you want to get mail and--
and parse it in your application
without having to deal
with, like sendmail
and--and--and dealing
with MindCrap or whatever.
Like, if you want--
like, you're prototyping
and you want to, like, accept
email in your application,
I built this thing
called "Mail Hook"
that's like--anything
you set this up with--
an MX record,
and then you say,
"Anything sent to this domain
will get posted to this URL."
And it was
a very simple system.
And it seems like,
you know,
other protocols
could be added to that
as an input into
the web hook ecosystem.
So but--
so smtp2web
is basically the same thing.
Although it's interesting,
because it was made
by the Google App Engine
community.
It's another way to accept mail
because Google App Engine
doesn't accept mail
right now.
And web hooks were
the obvious solution--
just an HTTP callback.
And then Rick Olson
from Lighthouse
has an open-source version
that will also do XMPP.
And he uses that
for Lighthouse.
But the smtpweb one
is interesting
because it was made
because of the limitations
of Google App Engine.
In fact, there
was a lot of these--
like micro webservices,
like a--a cron service,
where you just register
a URL for it to--
to post to that at some
particular time in the future
so that you could do
cron stuff with App Engine.
And then before there was
image stuff, there was like
these really focused
image manipulation things.
And it was kind of like
the first glimpse
at what, you know,
small-focused--I don't know,
micro webservices
that are like the equivalent
of grep and cat
and word count
and stuff
on the command line.
And so I would imagine,
you know,
if there is the infrastructure
for that kind of,
you know, piping on the web,
then you would get
more of those kinds of
small-focused web services.
And then there's
Martin and Andy,
two guys in the U.K.
that love web hooks.
They built this thing
called the "Spaghetti Junction"
at a Hack Day
and it invol--
it evolved into Switchub,
which is--
which I really love.
And I figured this
sort of thing would emerge
but I didn't think
it would happen
until web hooks
were more popular.
It's kind of like
the paste bin.
You know, it's a consumer
because it gives you URLs
that you can
put into various systems.
But then it basically
routes it to various outputs,
like "post to IRC"
or "email me."
And so it, like,
it starts--
you know, basically
what I figured would happen
was eventually
people would get sick
of writing one-off scripts
all the time,
and so people
would make services
that would do this kind
of stuff for other people,
and this is
an example of that.
But it's kind of nice
'cause you can
route things
all weird and stuff.
But it's very focused on--
on web hooks
and so I like it.
And--and what
they're gonna do
with the--the inputs
and output handlers
that you see
are very simple scripts
that they could implement
the same way
Github does their
service integration,
so that they can be run as
a separate web service locally
that can be open-sourced
so that the main Switchub
code can be private,
but the handlers
are open-sourced
so people can, you know,
fork it and contribute new ones
and then they can, you know,
easily just start using them.
And Switchub would benefit,
for example,
from a built-in input
for various other protocols
like email--like,
you know, using Mail Hook
but also RSS
and other things.
Maybe Jabber.
But instead of having
to build it themselves,
they can just work
with other services
to support
those kinds of inputs.
So for example,
RSS FWD,
which will take RSS
and email it to you,
they could easily just
also have a web hook
and then they can use that
and write a handler
for Switchub,
and then you can have
RSS as an input to this.
So it seems, you know,
a lot like Yahoo! Pipes
only better--
and real, you know.
I don't know.
RSS just didn't make sense
for all the cool stuff
that I really wanted to do.
So I started visualizing
how, you know,
if there was like a graphical
user interface to do it
it would probably kind of
look like Reason, you know--
inspired by
virtual rack mounts
and then you
can switch to the back
and like wire
everything how you want.
Like imagine these racks
are web services
and they have various events
and you can, like,
"Okay, take this one,
and I want the output
of this event to go
into the input of this one."
It will require,
you know, obviously
standardization or adapters
and stuff like this,
but, you know,
it seems possible
when the infrastructure
is there.
Like, you can't
really do this
unless there is something
like an HTTP callback
or something to actually
get data out
that's not something
poll-based.
So--Plugins. One more thing
that I want to talk about.
Before that,
though, a story.
So the web, you know, was
originally a bunch of pages
linked together--
static content.
It's kind of weird
to think of that now
because of the way
the web is now,
but it--
what happened was
people kept wanting
to access other things
through HTTP.
Like in this case,
what was it?
WAIS?
That's before my time.
But they wanted to get it,
you know, through HTTP,
and so they would
hack the web services--
the web servers
to do that.
And--so this was
before CGI.
And so they decided
to standardize this
and create the
Common Gateway Protocol,
which didn't make sense,
so they renamed it to "CGI."
And then as a--
as another side--tangent
in going through
these old mailing lists,
which is very fun.
This was posted on reddit
a while back but--
"and recent, proposing
the image tag for HTML."
And--and it was weird
because people fought it,
because they said it needed
to be more generalized
and work
for any type of media.
But, you know,
in the end,
he just put it in Mosaic
and then that was that, right?
And now it's everywhere.
So anyway, these pages
that were just static content,
today, because of CGI,
because of these hacks
and people starting
to use it more and more,
now for some reason,
our web is sort of, like,
generated by these
higher-order conceptual nodes
that are code.
They're apps.
Like, all of our web today,
pretty much, is generated
by applications.
And it's kind of weird
how that evolved.
So you have
these applications,
and the difference between
these layers is, you know,
it's kind of back
and front-end,
but it's not really
the same thing.
It's subtly different.
I'm talking about
like applications
and the pages
they generate.
You know, it's--
it's function and content.
And so it's
kind of interesting
to think that it was
the functionality part--
we had to wait
for the applications
to take over the web
for us to really
get the two-way content.
And so we have
the read-write web or whatever
and we can like easily
publish content on the web.
So web 2.0, whatever--
user-generated content.
I want user-contributed
or democratized
functionality, right?
That's kind of where
the programmability
starts coming in.
So not only integrating and
composing these applications
but also extending
applications.
So it's--I almost called
this section "Platforms"
because platforms
are really cool.
We all love them.
That's basically technology,
in essence.
The Facebook Platform
was pretty cool, I guess.
I asked a friend how it worked
and he said, "Web hooks."
And I was like, "What?"
Sure enough, I mean,
at a high level, conceptually,
it looks like
web hooks to me, right?
You know,
it's HTTP calling out,
using the results
of some other application
and brings it in and
displays it within Facebook--
you know,
essentially extending
the functionality of Facebook
with these applications.
There is not
a huge difference
between applications
and plugins.
So in fact,
a few other people have--
have done this,
where they actually take,
you know, the response
of these callbacks
to affect the logic
in their applications.
For example,
Dabble DB
which is, you know,
a hosted, you know--
create online databases.
And so when--for people
that shouldn't be using Excel.
Their plugin API
is basically web hooks,
and so the kinds of plugins
that you can make
are derived fields.
So I mean, it's like
a big spreadsheet, right?
And you can do derived fields
or whatever.
You can create
your own custom derived fields
that are calculated
by your code.
And so they made this
and it was like
their own standard where
they have this metadata thing
that basically just
points to a URL,
and that's a web hook,
right?
And of course
they compared it to Pipes--
the simplicity,
the natural fit for it.
But I think that
they should have hooks
for all the standard
CRUD events
because that would
make their applications
so much more useful.
Just the same way that,
you know, PayPal
is--has a hook
for their major event.
Like you can integrate it
with the rest of your workflow.
Because a lot of these,
you know, app platforms
like Coghead
and Salesforce,
they sort of--they're
sort of--they're siloed off--
you know, data processing
and the functionality
that they provide--
when you might
have existing stuff
that you want
to integrate with,
and it would be so much
easier if they had hooks
that you could hook into.
Amazon--this was
a fairly recent thing--
so not only do they have
you know, Instant Order
Processing Notifications
for events like
order creation, cancellation,
ready-to-ship stuff.
Checkout is basically
a check-out process
that you can use.
But they also
have these callbacks
that actually return stuff,
and they use that
so that you can use them
to calculate shipping costs
and taxes and promotions
and stuff like this.
So they're doing it.
I should really find out
how they're doing it
because of course
people are asking,
"What's the scalability
and all as such?"
IMified, another platform
that's using web hooks
to let you build
bots for IM
basically by calling out
to a web script.
So just to close, I want
to drop some GST on you.
The central tenet--
a central tenet is that
the value is not within
the elements themselves,
but the real value
is in the interactions
and how they work together
in systems,
and everything is a system
so this is sort of
a--a universal law, maybe?
And so this creates, you know,
the emergent phenomenon
of the system and
it defines its behavior.
So if we increase ways
to work together and have--
basically--web hooks
are, basically, you know,
new ways to interact
between applications,
that creates
new means of combination,
increases
the degrees of freedom,
and covers new opportunities
and business tools
and empowerment,
which is great.
That's what technology
is all about.
And, of course, the vision
for a programming paradigm
that is the Internet
or is the web
is very compelling,
but we're not there yet
because the real
programmable web
will require web hooks,
and that is
all I have to say--
unless you have questions,
which I can answer,
or try to.
[applause]
Was this interesting?
man:
Yes.
Lindsay:
Good.
Are you going to now
put web hooks
into all your applications?
Yes.
man #2:
So I've got a question
from a security standpoint.
Lindsay:
Yes.
man #2: Have you looked
at preventing somebody
from going and registering
hundreds and thousands
of web hooks on some server
that they want to--
or pointing toward some server
that they want
to launch a denial
of service attack against,
and how do you
prevent that?
Lindsay:
That's a very common...
woman:
Can you repeat the question?
Lindsay: So how do you prevent
denial of service attacks
from registering a bunch
of URLs and having them?
I mean, that's--
so services
are going to be in control
of, you know,
what they're posting to
and how often.
So some of the
implem-implementations
I've seen, including
the PubSubHubBub application
do are--are
just very careful
about that.
And they have
mechanisms for that
that I haven't
looked into yet.
But it's just being
a little bit more smart
about how you
implement these things.
More questions?
Yeah.
man #3:
So I saw a great example
of this recently.
I bought a Panasonic
network camera
that's remote-controllable,
you can change the direction
of the lens, and so on.
Lindsay:
Yeah.
man #3: And it has
in the setup options
a way of saying, "Post
the pictures that you get
"when motion is detected
to the following URL
by HTTP code."
Lindsay:
Yep.
man #3:
It works beautifully.
Lindsay:
So--
man #3:
Totally embedded.
Lindsay: Part of the--the bigger
vision here,
and I called this
the programmable web--
oh, so I don't know
if I need to repeat that,
but, I mean,
that was a really cool--
uh, what was it, a--a--
what was the device?
man #3:
Panasonic network camera.
Lindsay:
That's a network camera
that when it--
what was the thing
that it detects?
man #3:
It detects motion.
Lindsay:
Mo--when motion,
it posts--yeah.
And that's really cool.
Like, that's a web hook.
And it's really cool
'cause that's, like,
a physical thing.
A lot of people are
talking about, you know,
"Eventually the web will
be a web of things," right?
And so I called this talk
"The Programmable World
of Tomorrow"
because in my mind,
the world will become
more programmable.
So this is
an example of that,
and programming
will be more useful
than just doing stuff
on the web.
And having this kind of
universal programmability
built in
would be really nice.
So that is very cool.
Questions, comments?
Is that it?
Okay.
[applause]